et en ile de france justement les listes
d'attentes pour un logement social sont
très importantes selon la dernière étude
réalisée il y à 270 mille demandes non
satisfaites dans la région les raisons
de cette situation et les projections
pour l'avenir christine her 20 mètres
carrés en location sous les toits de
paris
une solution qui devait être transitoire
mais qui dure
elisabeth vite ici avec son compagnon et
leurs enfants maison 9000 francs de
revenus mensuels et a tenté un hlm
depuis quatre ans aujourd'hui nous ne
satisfont pas aux critères du privé tous
les deux mois je vais la mairie du 5e
expliquer qu'ici c'est beau mais c'est 7
mètres carrés habitables mais c'est
grand mais pour vivre c'est tout petit
alors pourquoi j'ai pas eu de réponse
avant mais je crois que je ne suis pas
la seule nous sommes nombreux elisabeth
veut un logement social dans la capitale
à l'image de beaucoup de demandeurs qui
choisissent paris et la petite couronne
là où il faut patienter plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années
plus l'on s'éloigne de paris plus le
délai sera court si la tente se
prolongent aussi car le taux de rotation
des hlm est faible 7 % du parc seulement
chaque année se libère dans la région
explications la situation financière des
locataires se dégrade
ils n'ont plus les moyens d'acheter et
les prix du privé sont trop élevés les
listes d'attentes s'allongent
je suis plutôt pessimiste que je ne vois
pas de raison aujourd'hui
objectif de penser qu'à la fois l'offre
de logements dans cette région se
développe à hauteur des besoins et
d'autre part je n'ai pas de raison de
penser que l'offre de logements sociaux
augmente je pense même qu'elle ira
plutôt en diminuant en se spécialisant
sur l'ultra sociale nous ne résolvons
pas le problème des classes modestes qui
ont besoin d'un logement social
et pour pallier la forte demande le
rythme des constructions ne suit pas
environ 15 mille logements sociaux
sortent de terre chaque année
ce que je voudrais c'est qu'on tienne
compte en termes de financement des
spécificités cette région sur des
problèmes fonciers des pommes de coût de
la construction et des problèmes de
pression de la demande
autre ombre au tableau les coupes dans
le budget du logement prévisible en 97
les organismes hlm s'inquiète du
contrecoup sur leurs listes d'attentes